So the answer, is yes, we have a good recursive
definition, no matter what we pass in for t and
p, we'll eventually get a result, and the reason for
that is because every time we do a recursive call, the
value that's passed in for t, is one less than
the previous value, and eventually, if we start with an integer.
And we keep reducing it, eventually we're going to get to
the case where t is equal to 0, and then we
have a base case. We can return the value one, without using the
popularity function again. So this is
a good recursive definition. It will always
produce a result. It might not produce a meaningful measure of popularity, but
if this is how we define popularity, this code will always produce a result.